bernat opi nació en parís en el seno de
una familia modesta después de un
accidente grave renunció a sus sueños de
ser piloto de carreras y se dedicó a los
negocios su campo el sector empresarial
y
para mí la unidad de medidas el dinero
soy negociante y hago a emprender a
todos los que me rodean con un deseo
feroz de ganar mucho mucho mucho dinero
con un cierto sentido de autopromoción
se convirtió en una personalidad
mediática muy querida por los franceses
a principios de los años 1980 en el
apogeo de su gloria se convirtió en
dueño de la marca adidas una empresa
cuya venta daría lugar a un conflicto
con el banco de lyon el empresario acusó
a la entidad de haberse llevado la mayor
parte de la plusvalía
en mayo de 2017 el tribunal de casación
ordenó la devolución de 404 millones de
euros al empresario siendo un hombre de
derecha tapiz se lanzó a la política
gracias al ex presidente françois
mitterrand paso por el ministerio de
ciudades y fue disfrutado pero su
principal hazaña fue el debate contra el
ultraderechista jean-marie le pen no es
porque tenga la boca grande y grite
fuerte que se acorte señor usted salió
de lo más bajo
pero no puedo ser cortés con usted su
carrera política estuvo marcada por su
compromiso contra el desempleo juvenil y
su absoluta oposición al frente nacional
de le pen
y también fue presentador de televisión
y actor de cine y teatro
en 2017 anunció públicamente que tenía
cáncer enfermedad que se extendió por
todo su cuerpo